faire revivre la perspective des loges
le domaine nationale de saint germain en
laye va voir renaître son grand bassin
un projet initié par louis xiv pour
donner de l'éclat aux jardins de la
résidence royale l'enjeu principal si
vous voulez c'est la restauration d'une
image une image très forte qui est celle
de la perspective de le nôtre qui avait
été dénaturé par la disparition du
bassin et donc la composition va être
retrouvée on avait une composition
triangulaire avec deux petits bassins
proche du château est un très grand
bassin dans laxe dans la perspective des
loges des travaux débutés il ya déjà
plusieurs mois avant la recréation du
bassin la première pierre a été
symboliquement déposée le jeudi 12
janvier aux chantiers rendue possible
grâce à l'arrivée du tram 13 et une
correspondance avec le rer a c'est une
prouesse
technique considérable parce qu'on voit
bien que les structures
les structures de transport sont à
arnaud à m un mètre de profondeur et
demandent des travaux des travaux
architecturaux extrêmement précis
extrêmement complexe donc coûteux c'est
effectivement 6,55 millions d'euros pour
restaurer pour remettre cette cette
pièce doute le projet voit le jour grâce
à un financement collectif le ministère
de la culture la ville de saint germain
en laye le département des yvelines la
région ile-de-france et des mécènes
privés la particularité de ce domaine
c'est qu'avec l'arrivée du tram on va
faire une jonction entre le domaine et
le parc de saint germain jusqu'au parc
de versailles
c'est unique ont recréé un axe majeur de
notre département est donc bien
évidemment ça va redonner beaucoup de
lustre et daf activités au domaine un
projet qui devrait prendre fin au
printemps prochain l'inauguration de
l'édifice est prévue le 17 septembre
2022 à l'occasion des journées
européennes du patrimoine